[Music]
musical spaces are gendered
the history of choral singing is that
women sing in high voices and
men sing in their lower voices and for
an individual for whom that model does
not fit choir is not really a space for
them
i'm really trying to create a new
tradition and create spaces for trans
and non-binary singers
great big story was made possible by
procter gamble
[Music]
i'm william sourland and i'm the
artistic director of the oakland gay
men's chorus
i'm
trying to make a new model for what a
men's chorus
can look like
we perform at the professional level in
big concerts halls in front of 2000
people all the way down to small church
venues with maybe 50 or 60 audience
members
the course is made up of gay men by men
trans men non-binary individuals
straight men cisgender women everyone is
allowed to have a place at the table
let's do that again let's go to the
whole page
[Music]
i wouldn't characterize having trans or
non-binary singers in a chorus as a
challenge
if you have a trans singer who's going
through a vocal change it might mean
allowing them to move the vocal parts as
their voice deepens or changes in some
way
i want anybody who feels like their
voice has been silenced to make their
voice even louder
[Music]
[Music]
i have always loved singing
i sang
with the symphony but i was in the alto
section and i really wanted to be in the
section behind me they got to wear tuxes
i had to wear a dress
when i decided to transition
i found that there were places that
didn't want me i felt like i had to
apologize for who i was
when i joined the chorus i'd been afraid
because i thought my voice stood out too
much
it's like it's not masculine enough
i felt so self-conscious because my
voice is different
it's different from theirs
i want my voice to be like theirs but
you know that's a hard journey
some days it seems like
love's in short supply
once i got in there and started making
friends i felt like i had walked into a
family of so many brothers
i take my kid out the rehearsals and
al had a whole bunch of uncles
suddenly i was in a place where i could
start just being
me
and they let me be comfortable
ready
[Music]
in one of the shows i got to sing this
solo
when i was done billy blew me a kiss
and in that moment
i knew
my voice
as david was accepted
it was okay for me to be me
[Music]
we are not taking any step back by
having trans and non-binary singers our
sound does not suffer in fact it's the
opposite
we actually sound
better because of these singers
our community and our sense of family is
even stronger because we have said in an
outward way
that you were all welcome
and music is the thing that brings us
together
you